Chris Pratt reveals how he prepared for
nude scenes in his new film passengers
it's a really deep mental preparation
alongside his co-star Jennifer Lawrence
the 37-year old actor dish to eat ease
Carly steel about the grueling task of
getting naked on screen so really deep
mental preparation needed to show your
butt on camera Chris reveals squats
weren't involved at all no no gosh no I
did get a little tan though I got a
little spray tan that's my that's way I
prepare I'm happy with the way it looked
you know and that's just what my butt
looks like all the time by the way what
it looks like right now he's took it off
he also told a hilarious story about
when his four-year-old son Jack visited
them on set it's funny because jack has
been Jack's been on set to visit me on
on every movie that I've done since he's
been alive from the last four years and
he's getting really comfortable with the
idea of sitting behind the monitors
wearing the cans watching the monitors
he's like a little director you know and
there was a moment they where he was
behind the monitors where the director
and the producers sit you know watching
what's happening on camera and he just
had his hands on and he's looking
through his little glasses the monitor
and he just said can I get a coconut
water and he wasn't like talking to
anyone necessarily which is totally
terrible behavior that we do all the
time or you just like throw a random
request into the ether and expect
someone to deliver it I mean as we're
totally spoiled brat are the actors
[Music]
you